E aí
[Música]
há alguns anos atrás no jantar de amigos
cá em casa o micro-ondas deixou de
funcionar e neste momento é um
equipamento de quase indispensável no
nosso dia-a-dia doméstico o que acontece
é que é a sugestão de alguns que estavam
no jantar foi imediatamente pensar em ir
ao supermercado mais próximo e comprar
um novo realmente micro-ondas já tinham
aspecto amarelado já tinha muitos anos
de funcionamento e se calhar estava
mesmo a precisar de ter substituído a
a ideia foi Contrariar
e esta tendência que nos vem para o
maior consumo acabamos por mandar
arranjar o micro-ondas e ele ainda
continua a funcionar e vai até a luz que
já não funcionava acabou por vou estar
voltar a estar ligada e portanto
consumir um bocadinho mais quando a
porta abre mas a mensagem é muito
simples nós temos fazer o exposto na na
forma compensamos de modo a evitar
realmente consumirão mais recursos do
planeta e isso é o principal problema
que nós temos é uma Pegada Ecológica que
no caso dos portugueses nos obrigaria a
se todos vivessem como nós a termos 2,3
planetas aquilo que é renovado todos os
anos obriga-nos portanto a
um recurso muito para além daquilo que
natureza nos dá portanto vale a pena
percebemos o que é que nós no dia a dia
podemos e devemos fazer para apostar nos
três erres Ou seja é para realmente
trazermos em redução a reutilização EA
reciclagem é na Ida ao supermercado que
é nós tomamos a maioria das decisões
importantes primeiro porque calhar
Devíamos Estar ao mercado adquirir
produtos locais mais próximos não vem de
muito longe com enorme pegada carbônica
e está
e aqui na informação da maior parte dos
bens que nós consumimos e portanto faz
toda a diferença porque muitos deles é
também vai em com grande parte de
embalagem podia e devia ser evitada
outra divisão tenho precisamente a ver
com o tipo de costume que nós fazemos
nós desperdiçamos muito quer do ponto de
vista de muitos bens é como se diários
até ao desperdício alimentar falar em
alimentação e nós somos o terceiro povo
do mundo que mais peixe com sal 62 kg em
média por pessoa por ano a nossa frente
só Coreia do Sul EA Noruega
bom e quando falamos de proteína animal
então aí temos que o consumo de carne é
de 127 kg por pessoa por ano ora isto é
insustentável para a nossa saúde mas
também sustentável para o planeta é a
carne já está no segundo nível da cadeia
alimentar já se perdeu muita energia e
com todos os fertilizantes Vitória troll
os alimentos que é tudo do Gado e das
emissões de gases de efeito estufa de
agravo outras climáticas principalmente
no gado bovino o impacto enorme nós
temos de saber escolher alimentos mais
uma vez que são de época locais com
pouca embalagem e fazer um investimento
na proteína vegetal não precisamos de
recusar totalmente o
é de carne Mas temos que cresceu
fortemente pelos impactos que acabamos
por ter e agora que estamos a falar de
ir às compras vale a pena falarmos de
mobilidade porque é a forma como nos
movemos é decisiva também nas emissões
de gases com efeito estufa é E nós
queremos uma sociedade descarbonizada é
nós temos que fazer um esforço na
mobilidade do ave na mobilidade ativa
que também melhor a nossa saúde e não em
gastarmos mais gasolina e gasóleo vamos
pensar um pouco sobre isto nós temos um
quarto das nossas emissões de gases de
efeito estufa em Portugal esse piadas ao
sector dos transportes Principalmente ao
transporte rodoviário e esse transporte
rodoviário é feito na maior parte das
vezes é conosco sozinhos e no automóvel
automóvel que pesa
é mais do que uma tonelada grandes
transportar a apenas contigo sozinhos em
distâncias consideráveis em ligações
muitas das vezes pendulares ou seja do
dia a dia precisamos de apostar no uso
do transporte público é sem dúvida que
nós temos também que procurar optar por
um veículo elétrico é cada vez está mais
barato apesar de não ser fácil nós temos
um de carregar temos que garantir que
eletricidade é a de fontes renováveis
precisamos também aqui de olhar para
todo o ciclo de vida do automóvel
elétrico e garantir que realmente as
baterias os materiais acabam por ser um
galho em relação ao gasóleo e gasolina e
isso já
é provável e portanto é um bom
investimento mas o carro é realmente
digamos a última opção em comparação com
o uso do Autocarro que o uso por exemplo
de alguns percursos a pé ou de bicicleta
é que fazem toda a diferença do ponto de
vista de uma mobilidade que deve também
contribuir para melhorar a nossa saúde a
e na mobilidade passamos para um outro
aspecto o nível digamos assim é esta
realidade da do consumo de energia que é
a necessidade que nós temos de sermos
mais eficientes nos no interior de
nossas casas na gestão que fazemos do
nosso dia a dia em termos de conforto
térmico hora isso passa obviamente por é
em primeiro lugar procurarmos eliminar
muitos equipamentos que estão sempre
ligados e que é escusável está a gastar
electricidade em segundo lugar nós
procurávamos melhorar francamente O
isolamento de nossas casas é isso passa
por instalar os por exemplo uma uma
segunda janela substituirmos por vidros
duplos é fazermos por exemplo apenas 1
o orçamento da casa com todas as janelas
abertas durante 23 minutos para fazer a
renovação da qualidade do ar em vez de
termos as janelas abertas durante mais
tempo nos dias de maior calor e nos dias
de maior frio e e portanto assim
garantir um maior conforto térmico com o
menor gasto de energia e o investimento
comercial é precisamente também na na
capacidade que nos é dada e através de
um dois painéis na varanda no telhado
nós podemos é produzir eletricidade que
vamos utilizar um chamado autoconsumo é
muito fácil fica pago ao fim de três
quatro anos a energia solar
Seja bem vindo a ser cada vez mais
barata no que diz respeito à produção de
electricidade E se tivermos por exemplo
uma Vivenda podemos e devemos recorrer a
água quente suave em vez de usar um gás
ou eletricidade é para a água sanitária
que utilizamos na cozinha e
principalmente nos olhos Por falar em
baixos em nossas casas e eficiência
hídrica é também o aspecto comercial e é
isso ainda não substituímos é por
exemplo os chuveiros por caudais menores
que são possíveis através de dispositivo
de chamado chamado redutores de caudal
que podem estar com Digno chuveiros mas
também nas várias torneiras em casa se
ainda não colocamos uma garrafa de litro
e meio cheia de água dentro do
autoclismo
a descarga são habitualmente 567 litros
e portanto nós podemos obviamente aí ter
uma contribuição grande se regular os
autoclismos posso poder um objeto grande
dentro do depósito então está na altura
certa de o fazemos como sabemos as
alterações climáticas estão levar a
períodos de seca cada vez maiores e nós
temos que ter bem mais poupados no uso
deste bem tão precioso gostaria agora
apenas de vos dar uma ideia da palavra
mais importante que nos deve fazer
reflectir no nó diária é palavra
suficiência é mais importante do que a
eficiência é no fundo nós percebemos que
há de ver
é apenas consumir o que precisamos e não
desperdiçar é este o nosso lema na água
nem energia nos resíduos é mesmo na na
na mobilidade é nós devemos fazer o
esforço nestes tempos difíceis que
corremos por causa da pandemia e em que
experimentamos de pagar menos ruído
melhor qualidade do ar um consumo mais
local de vários produtos nós temos um
planeta claramente ameaçado em que é nós
podemos e devemos fazer a diferença e
sem dúvida que os políticos têm essa
responsabilidade mas estão as nossas
opções do dia a dia que é fazem a
diferença diretamente para nós em termos
ambientais
os cursos que dão o sinal as empresas e
que dão o sinal a quem nos governa as
próximas décadas tem mesmo que ser
décadas de sustentabilidade e portanto
vamos dar esse contributo para no nosso
dia a dia conseguimos promover um
planeta é que fique para as próximas
gerações com melhor qualidade para todos
e também para esta terra que é 11
E aí
[Música]